[Applaudissements]
j'arrive à mon pied est brisé évidemment
je ne vous le cache pas c'est honteux et
désastreux mais
c'est comme ça c'est la vie est
d'ailleurs en parlant de désastre
en voici un ça c'est moi alors 2011 j'ai
16 ans ça fait mal
ça ça fait aussi mal c'est moi l'autre
matin puis c'est toujours pas d'iphone
mais c'est la vérité que la différence
donc je pense qu'on peut voir entre ces
deux photos là c'est évidemment bon
glos web je l'espère vous me direz parce
que sinon c'est qu'il ya un problème
également l'évolution des cernes
peut-être j'ai pas mal regardé de tout
au youtube pour du make-up je peux ça se
voit mais la seule chose je pense qu'ils
se voient pas ou peut-être que ça se
vend si j'ai bien fait ma job c'est que
il ya une chose comme une secte dans ces
deux photos là j'ai toujours beaucoup
pleurer puis beaucoup créé et c'est un
peu ça le sujet dont je vais parler à
soir parce que ça fait vraiment mal puis
c'est tous les jours mais c'est le fun
fait que ça c'est ce que je crains quand
j'avais 16 ans donc c'est une
représentation tout à fait réaliste
comme vous pouvez le voir parce que
c'est ce que je crée ce matin tout
simplement en toute humilité est-ce
qu'on peut qu'on peut se poser comme
question c'est qu'est ce qui a mené à ce
changement de perspective finalement sur
sur dix ans et ce qui fait que chez
aujourd'hui en train de vous parler de
santé mentale de ma santé mentale en
tout cas un peu trop ouvertement un
public c'est tout simplement le fait que
j'ai découvert parce que c'était la
passion puis la passion ça fait une
grosse différence dans le sens où tu as
toujours envie de mourir un matin quand
tu te réveilles mais tu dis qu
potentiellement de ce pourrait peut-être
faire quelque chose quand tu votes
relevé si tu as envie de te lever fuck
cette passion-là pour moi je la vois
comme un canal isr d'émotion qui est
fait d'émotions positives qui est
négative qui vont se rencontrer en un
point focal et qui va générer une
réfraction d'énergie pis si en
l'occurrence de l'énergie créative en
tout cas dans mon corps c'est un peu
avec énergie là puisque passion là que
tu te retrouve un peu à l'aveuglé dans
ta vie à faire des choses que tu aurais
pas forcément pensé faire c'est un matin
c'est comme tu es en 2018 du coup plus
du tout les cheveux de tes amis dans un
parking mais tu te retrouves a gradué et
une maîtrise du design tu as écrit un
mémoire des genres 80000 si le design du
livre qui la relation que ça avec la
psyché humaine pis tout que du fun et et
ce bain ça marche ça m'a pris en fait
comme jean sept ans à comprendre que
c'était ça ma passion et que c'était ce
que je voulais faire de ma vie qui sinon
ben et poche dans vos comptes après 106
tard mais en même temps je suis vraiment
reconnaissante parce que ça fait partie
de ce processus là du travail créateur
et de toutes les crises qu'on peut
rencontrer dans sa vie au cours de sa
vie quand on se cherche et qu'on essaie
de comprendre qui on est et que c'est
tellement difficile parce que crime ça
fait mal là des fois t'es comme pourquoi
je suis comme ça puis ces crises là il
s'avère que quand on vient à parler de
santé mentale
pi2 processus créateur ses crises ses
quelque chose d'avéré et ces deux
éléments c'est des choses qui sont
intimement liés dans un schéma infinie
ici c'est ce que par exemple l'auteur
didier anzieu lui va appeler les cinq
phases du travail créateur et chacune de
ses cinq phases sont considérés comme
des crises donc par exemple en premier
lieu de se voir ta crise de saisissement
genre you faut que je passe de quoi j'ai
besoin j'ai un besoin de faire quelque
chose mais c'est instinctif dans un
second temps tête à deuxième crise qui l
est a prise de conscience de ce besoin
donc là qu'ils assimilent le fait que tu
as envie de faire quelque chose ce qui
est déjà beaucoup et dans un troisième
temps tu vas devoir décoder ce besoin là
parce que ce besoin là il faut le
comprendre et il faut appréhender sa
mise en forme ce qui nous amène par la
suite à la crise numéro 4 la plus fun la
plus détestée et aussi parce que c'est
la phase de la négociation et de la et
finalement du processus créateur qui lui
engendre beaucoup de sentiments comme
une remords les regrets la frustration
que des trucs vraiment nice qu'on a
envie de ressentir aux cantiques au
quotidien n'est ce pas
en tout cas moi j'ai envie bizarrement
je sais pas pourquoi je le fais
jusqu'à aller à la cinquième crise
quelle est la crise de l'achèvement de
la dite création est donc un peu c'est
finalement le deuil de cette création
lol et en plus cette création va falloir
que tu la confronte au regard externe
des autres nice ce père comme si ce
n'était pas assez difficile donc c'est à
ce moment-là à cette crise de 0,5 là que
ya potentiellement
une bonne possibilité en fait que la
boucle se referme encore parce que c'est
quand tu vas achevée et confronter sa
création au regard de l'autre et la
laisser partir que tu vas pouvoir re
générique ce sentiment dessaisissement à
la suite qui va peut-être te faire créer
quelque chose d'autre c'est donc à nice
tout ça fait tout seul c'est bon j'ai
enfin fait qu
il s'avère que moi ces processus de
création là et puis toutes les choses
que je dis je pense que je prends ça un
peu trop à coeur parce que j'ai décidé
de faire de cette vulnérabilité l'appui
de ces crises genre mon image de marque
tellement une bonne idée pas pourquoi
mais il s'avère que on va retrouver ça
partout
partout comme vous pouvez le voir ici
dans mon nom d'artiste qui vient de
cette superbe idée phrase déclaration
suivie d'une belle appropriation
linguistique hispanique je m'en excuse
pour se terminer en ce nom d'artiste qui
donc mal à vis d'eux et qui est pas
super finalement pour juste le dire
rapidement et mettre beaucoup dehors au
milieu puis ça passe on le retrouve
également dans mon positionnement en
tant qu'artiste ce que j'appelle aussi
bon slogan parce qu'on essaye de les
rendre un peu plus compréhensible marque
slogans et
c'est ça c'est je le mets partout puis
comme ça je m'assure que les gens
comprennent un peu ce que je fais en une
seule phrase parce que faut dire que ce
que je fais c'est quand même assez
abstrait vous le savez peut-être parce
que vu que vous avez tous lu ma bio
n'est ce pas parce que moi j'ai écrit je
veux dire j'ai mis tout mon coeur là
dedans j'espère que vous l'avez lu
sinon je fais pleurer dans ma bio ses
marques et un donc
sensibilité émotionnelle santé mentale
tout ça tout est marqué puis on va le
retrouver aussi dans mes oeuvres donc
mes oeuvres abstraites qui sont éclairés
par des titres un peu moins abstrait et
finalement tout ça ça crée cette image
de marque ce est persona de mal à vis
d'eux j'ai mal à la vie ok wheller fait
finalement moi c'est tout tout cette
image de marque cette minable
vulnérabilité tout ça c'est devenu un
peu comme
mon moteur créatif évidemment mais aussi
ben ma maison j'appelle ça ma maison
parce que c'est comme je suis dans ma
petite place d'un confort qui je suis
confortable là dedans c'est ça fait mal
pis iphone c'était si toi aussi tu étais
un peu taper des troupes des difficultés
à gérer pas santé mentale tu sais un peu
ce que c'est que l'anxiété des fois tu
étais un peu confortable là dedans alors
sens où tu peux pas trop en sortir parce
que tu la connais bien qu'elle te
connais bien puis ça s'est un peu ma
situation maintenant là mais où est ce
que je décide d'enfer de se c'est que je
me positionne en tant que est designer
de l'émotion designer de l'émotion pour
moi c'est quoi c'est finalement faire de
skim me fait me sentir mal à tous les
jours quelque chose qui veut peut-être
générer ces autres phases de
saisissement de prise de conscience qui
d'introspection chez l'autre là pour que
peut-être à son tour cette personne-là
fasse la même chose avec l'autre et
qu'on génère un peu c'est une réaction
en chaîne où on va aller essayer de se
tirer un peu vers le haut parce que bon
on sait que c'est tough la vie mais on
aura tôt fait fake c'est un peu ça mon
devoir et site et cette relation là
cette réaction en chaîne elle pourrait
pas exister finalement si la relation en
fait entre le créateur donc six mois
l'oeuvre est la personne qui va
témoigner de cette loi n'existait pas ça
pourrait pas exister et finalement c'est
à travers cette relation là qu'on va
développer une fonction empathique c'est
pour cela que le designer de l'émotion
pour moi à mon sens arrive et fait sa
job un peu dans l'ombre c'est on est pas
on n'est pas là pour servir une fonction
traditionnelle de vendre quelque chose
de communiquer vraiment message de
marque quoi que ce soit on est là pour
faire pour pour véhiculer une réflexion
qui est très subjective à chacun
et donc ça me fait penser tu vois on est
tous on est un peu tous dans le mal au
fond parce que tout le monde un peu
ses difficultés ses propres troupes ses
propres trauma extérieur mais dans cette
relation là d'intimité on est quand même
ensemble et ça nous rapproche justement
via cette honnêteté émotionnel qu'on
peut avoir au quotidien avec l'autre et
danse concret et c'est pour ça que ça me
rappelle souvent l'os de cette citation
d tennessee williams que bon je sais
j'avoue je les ai entendus dans les
frères scott là mais bon c'est pas si
vous connaissez pas c'est à dire que je
suis vraiment vieilli bon j'ai pas
encore 27 ans la savane on
met donc cette citation de mon chum
tennessee williams qui dit la solitude
est un sentiment partagé par tellement
de gens que ce serait extrêmement
égoïste d'éprouver sa solitude tout seul
ce qui en soit dans un sens dans une
certaine lecture est assez vrai parce
que
on a on a sept variables inconnues qu'on
connaît pas qu'on n'arrive pas à
appréhender
puis on on met tellement d'efforts a
juste rester dans son coin piel tes
affaires nos petites affaires à espérer
que quelqu'un il voit ou pas que
quelqu'un s'y intéresse ou pas
puis tout ce qui nous fait le mal on va
le garder pour soi parce qu'on veut pas
déranger personne mais finalement c'est
un peu tout ça compte contre quoi je me
bats notamment pour moi mais pour les
autres aussi et cette variable inconnu
qui est quoi qui est contenu dans ce que
puisque contient pas pleurer et crée
finalement
moi je l'exploit depuis six ans
officiellement qu'il s'étoffe pas si
c'est ça veut dire c'est l'ondé et donc
je l'export en tant que designer
graphique jeu l'expert en tant
qu'artiste puis je l'export aussi en
tant que plus récemment crypto artistes
occitans un terme un peu floue là pour
dire que je crée certifie et vends mes
oeuvres dans le contexte du mail
heureuse comme mâcon part cela bien
citer tantôt
notamment aux nudistes et en utilisant
le système des nfc ou jetons dans
fongible pour les intimes que vous avez
dont vous avez peut-être certainement
entendu parler récemment pour x ou y
raisons diverses et variées bonne ou
mauvaise controversé ou pas ce sera à
vous de juger moi je suis pas là pour
vous expliquer ça mais je suis là pour
vous parler justement de ce sentiment de
liberté de création et de liberté de
ressentir dans le contexte du web 3
encore une fois charlotte
est en fait ceci web trois là qu'est ce
que c'est de ce maire a reçu web 3 et
pourquoi c'est utile pour les créatifs
pour les créateurs parce que
ce web 3 que l'on considère comme le
meilleur c'est finalement un système
des technologies du web qui basé sur la
technologie delà de la chaîne de blocs
et donc de la bloque chain pour les
anglophones
en comparaison est en opposition en fait
au web 2 qui lui considéré comme le web
social que l'on connaît tous maintenant
et
alors ouais dit comme ça j'avoue le mail
art eux c'est un peu
après on peut un peu oui un peu pourquoi
je voudrais faire des koalas dedans ça a
l'air froid ça al'air controversé pie
tout et comment je peux moi exprimer ma
vulnérabilité aux yeux de tous danser
mais les russes dans ce web 3 alors que
c'est déjà difficile dans le web 2
pourquoi entrer ça ben moi aussi je me
posais la question qui s'avère que
depuis comme une bonne année maintenant
donc depuis début janvier ben j'ai
rencontré tous ces gens là qui en tout
cas une grosse partie sont pas tous là
mais tous ces gens qui
en fait d'un culte yves la même envie
que moi la même envie de démocratiser la
vulnérabilité de démocratiser l'art et
l'artiste aussi en lui-même en tant
qu'individu qu'on a trop souvent
désolidariser en fait de la création
elle-même et et qu'on nous en tant que
créateur on se désolidarise souvent
aussi de cette création la au profit de
mettre en lumière notre oeuvre et
parfois on finit par s'oublier donc on
me dit un petit peu pour ça et est en
fait évidemment tout ça c'est très très
inconnue le web 3 les élèves qui le
mènera vers celle angoisse totale chaque
jour
parce que ces inconnus est en fait qu
idy a connu dix potentiellement est
définitivement anxiété et pas que pour
moi pas que pour des gens qui ont une
tendance à l'anxiété de base mais pour
des gens qui découvrent ça et qui ont
envie de créer qui ont envie de montrer
ce qu'ils savent faire au monde mais
c'est paralysant en fait de découvrir
des choses nouvelles parce que c'est
plein d'incertitudes et comme vous le
savez sûrement l'anxiété c'est aussi
cette tendance à vouloir et avoir besoin
d'anticiper le lendemain de quoi sera
fait demain parce que il ya ce besoin de
réassurance de réconfort et de trouver
une réponse à ce qu'on ne connaît pas et
en fait je me suis rendu compte que tous
les gens que je rencontrais avait cette
même question puis on est juste là on se
regarde mais on n'en parle pas c'est
moins jusqu'à mais on est on est on est
ko pourquoi on fait ça donc je me suis
dit je fais juste créer une place dans
laquelle on voit juste pour voir se
regrouper
on veut pouvoir parler de ça peut-être
si on est confortable dans notre
inconfortable on va réussir à s'en
parler et du coup j'ai créé cette chose
cette merveilleuse chose que j'aurais
jamais pensé créer de ma vie et qui en
fait était quelque chose que j'avais
toujours eu envie de faire mais j'en
avais pas conscience cette chose-là
séjour de dix ans et en fait club de
sport émotion dans le média russe qui
vise évidemment à offrir ce qu'on a vu
ce qu'on appellerait un type space à la
portée de la main à tous les membres et
les utilisateurs qui le désiraient donc
dans cet espace là on a évidemment des
créatifs on a des collectionneurs d'art
on a des gens qui sont pas du tout
créatif qui viennent d'un background
vraiment plus administratif ou plus de
gestion de marque etc on a beaucoup de
profils qui se rencontrent et qui crée
quelque chose de nouveau et qui crée une
nouvelle symbiose et dans cette symbiose
leurs nouveaux champs d'action on va
avoir deux grands champs d'action
finalement ça va être nos activités
communautaires que là par exemple on
nomme majoritairement sur disques world
est
donc dans nos et donc on va parler et
démocratiser cette idée de la
vulnérabilité cette sensibilité à la
santé mentale dans nos discussions
journalières dans nos interventions
publiques aussi et dans un second temps
on est ce qu'on appelle notre
comment dire une aventure crypto
artistique qui vise à représenter la
métaphore du voyage vers la guérison
pas mal
donc dit comme ça parce qu'un peu wing
mais en fait il s'avère que visualiser
ces phases là de l'évolution de la
psyché et de l'évolution vers une santé
mentale en fait améliorer la mener comme
ça ça peut être très salvateur
que ce soit pour moi qui créent ces
visuels là où pour les gens qui en
témoignent et qui en font des choses et
ce qu'ils veulent ce qu'ils en veulent
finalement parce que ça leur appartient
une fois qu'ils ont ces visuels là et
dense est dans cette optique là on
essaie à travers ces deux champs
d'action de pouvoir
définir un web trois médailles heureuse
qui au-delà du fait d'être une
révolution
oui technologique et artistique pourrait
aussi être une révolution pour la santé
mentale pour la sensibilité émotionnelle
et pour finalement rendre cesser cet
univers de base du web qui lui a
toujours été un petit peu anonyme froid
et un peu moins chaleureux que ce qu'on
aurait souhaité et
moi je suis vraiment très très
reconnaissante évidemment de ça mais
c'est de la job lé fait que avant que
tout ça se fasse on va continuer à
acheter de l'intérieur
si ça tombe pas là
puis on va toi et moitié continue pas
mal pleurer je te le cache pas on va
peut-être créer des trucs dont on sera
pas fier ou des trucs qu'on sera un peu
plus content de ce qu'on a fait et on va
beaucoup souffrir puis ça va être
vraiment difficile mais ce qu'on veut
c'est pouvoir imaginer ce demain là un
demain où on va peut-être pouvoir se
dire et que moi je vais peut-être
pouvoir me réveillais en me disant ok
aujourd'hui ça va bien là c'est sa merci
[Applaudissements]